federal prosecutors say they forted an
Isis terror plot that targeted New York
City three men allegedly planned to set
off explosives in Times Square on
subways and at concert venues CBS News
justice reporter Paula Reid is in our
Washington bureau this morning with the
latest poll of good morning good morning
newly unsealed court documents alleged
three men from Canada Pakistan and the
Philippines use Internet messaging apps
to plan attacks in New York City in the
summer of 2016 now prosecutors say they
kept the details of this Isis inspired
plot secret until yesterday because
federal investigators want to determine
if there were any other people involved
now the men allegedly wanted to set off
bombs in Times Square attack New York
subways and target people attending
concerts they allegedly made reference
to the 2015 attacks in France at the
Bataclan theater saying we just walk in
with guns in our hands that's how the
Paris guys did it now one of the
plotters allegedly purchased an array of
bomb-making materials in Canada and also
rented a cabin near New York City where
he wanted to build explosive devices the
plot was actually broken up in May of
2016 now prosecutors say when the men
were discovered communicating about
terrorism an FBI undercover agent soon
made contact with them and they three
were under close surveillance one has
now pleaded guilty the other two are
under arrest awaiting extradition to the
US Alex Paula read in our Washington
bureau thanks Paula